[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 15 juin voici le programme de
ce soir la préfecture des Yvelines
estime les risques de sécheresse pour
cet été particulièrement élevé alors
pour éviter des probables feux de forêt
les pompiers des Yvelines doivent
s'adapter elles ont suivi récemment une
formation il y a deux semaines un
premier incendie s'est déclaré à
proximité de son champ une soirée
spéciale latina de la comédie de la
danse ou encore des pièces de théâtre
qui nous font réfléchir sur les mots de
notre société la prochaine saison
culturelle du théâtre Coluche à plaisir
vous promet de vivre de fortes émotions
les détails ce soir avec la directrice
de la salle et puis comme d'habitude le
jeudi à l'approche du week-end nous vous
donnerons nos idées de sortie dans les
Yvelines au programme les prochaines
brocantes dans le département de la
danse ou encore un festival de jazz mais
aussi du sport avec la semaine du Beach
du volley on en parle avec notre invité
qui est un gâteau avec nous ce soir ils
vendrait Valo bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
êtes le vice-président du club du
Vésinet stade saint-germain-nois
volley-ball et à partir de demain et
jusqu'à dimanche prochain vous
participez à la première édition de la
Semaine du beach volley c'est un
événement apporté national est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer en quelques
mots c'est quoi cette semaine du beach
volley alors tout d'abord c'est un
événement ne pas manquer dans la région
et dans le département c'est un
événement innovant c'est la première
fois qu'en France on organise un
événement avec un triptyque handicap
éducation et au niveau et donc nous
aurons pendant ces trois journées du
haut niveau avec les 20 meilleurs paires
françaises de Beach volley-ball donc du
2 qui viendront donc je dirais sur les
trois terrains que nous avons montés à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc s'affronter
et nous aurons tout un volet aussi
handicap on aura du volet assis ainsi
ainsi que du volet fauteuil pas sur du
ça mais sur du dur et puis on a aussi
l'ancien challenge un tel établissement
scolaire pour les lycéens et donc on
aura donc les finales vendredi soir donc
un beau programme que vous ne devez pas
manquer un beau programme dont on
détaillera tout à l'heure enfin
démission ce sera dans notre partie
loisir avec nous également sur ce
plateau le lieutenant-colonel Stéphane
Horn bonsoir alors vous êtes le référent
feu de forêt pour le 10 78 le service
départemental d'incendie et de secours
des Yvelines alors les pompiers des
Yvelines ont récemment suivi une
formation sur les gestes à connaître
pour mieux lutter contre les feux de
forêt et pour cause la météo des forêts
le nouvel outil de météo France a placé
le département des Yvelines en vigilance
jaune concernant les feux de forêt la
situation devient de plus en plus
préoccupante j'ai l'impression alors oui
la situation est de plus en plus
préoccupante donc il y a eu les grands
feux de 2022 mais même avant il y avait
déjà eu des grands feux la situation ne
fait que s'empirer et maintenant en fait
ce qui était avant un risque assez
particulier le feu de forêt surtout pour
le département des Yvelines devient de
plus en plus un risque courant donc en
fait il y a des actions pour former de
plus en plus les pompiers pour la Foire
répondre aux risques incendie dans le
département bien sûr répondre aux
colonnes de renfort partout en France
dans quelques instants plus en détail
dans cette émission nous parlerons
également de culture le théâtre Coluche
à Plaisir révèle sa nouvelle saison
culturelle demain soir pour en parler
avec nous Florence Camon bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes la directrice de la salle en
quelques mots à quoi faut-il s'attendre
pour cette nouvelle saison culturelle
une saison très différente avec beaucoup
beaucoup de dominantes joyeuses beaucoup
de spectacles beaucoup plus de
spectacles familiaux beaucoup d'humour
et puis des sujets mais ultra forts des
anniversaires et un ou deux événements
un peu fou où tout le bâtiment théâtre
Coluche sera mobilisé pour jusqu'au bout
de la nuit et donc on reviendra sur
cette programmation dans quelques
instants également avec nous une
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
Céline bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde avec
vous on verra les informations à retenir
dans les Yvelines ce sera juste après
les prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
matin le ciel sera toujours aussi bleu
lui il fera beau sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera 21 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles et 20 degrés à Houdan et
Rambouillet dans l'après-midi le ciel
sera toujours assez dégagé côté
température il fera 28 degrés à
Versailles 29 degrés à Houdan et
Rambouillet et 30 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et demain nous fêterons
les Régis le point maintenant sur
l'actualité à retenir dans les Yvelines
et on commence avec un chiffre Céline
c'est le chiffre 7 pourquoi alors 7 sur
10 Mathilde c'est le nombre divinois
ayant des difficultés à trouver un
logement dans le département chaque
année ce sont en moyenne 8930 logements
collectifs ou individuels qui sont
construits dans les Yvelines un chiffre
qui peut paraître élevé mais avec la
croissance démocratique démographique en
Île-de-France les besoins sont en
constante évolution en effet ce sont 50
000 nouveaux franciliens qui intègrent
la région chaque année le problème la
construction de logements neufs a baissé
de 44% entre 2022 et 2023 le département
des Yvelines regrette l'absence de
mesure concrètes lors des annonces
gouvernementales du Conseil national de
la refondation le 5 juin dernier avec
les acteurs de l'immobilier on va parler
de santé maintenant à l'approche de
l'été les difficultés dans les hôpitaux
risques de s'accentuer c'est pourquoi
l'agence régionale de santé va lancer un
nouvel outil tout à fait Mathilde dans
les hôpitaux les terribles souvent avec
baisse du nombre de lits et pénuries du
personnel pour l'Île-de-France les
autorités estiment la capacité d'accueil
à 80% entre le 10 juillet et le 27 août
pour faire face assez difficultés
l'agence régionale de santé va mettre en
ligne une carte sur son site internet
l'idée de mettre en avant les
consultations possibles sans rendez-vous
mais ils ont médical de garde et maison
de santé ouverte ainsi que les horaires
disponibles seront proposés l'objectif
et d'éviter un afflux de patients aux
urgences ce nouvel outil sera disponible
dès le mois de juillet prochain et dès
demain jusqu'à dimanche prochain ce sera
la troisième édition des Journées
Nationales de l'agriculture oui Mathilde
pendant ces trois jours de nombreuses
manifestations seront organisées partout
en France l'objectif favorisait les
échanges entre le public et les
professionnels de l'agriculture pour
montrer la place centrale de ce secteur
dans notre société au programme
animation visite des exploitations ou
découvertes des produits cette année
l'accent sera mis sur la diversité des
métiers l'occasion de mettre en avant la
souveraineté alimentaire proposée en
France dans les Yvelines c'est près
d'une vingtaine d'exploitations qui
accueilleront le public toutes les
informations sont à retrouver sur le
site qui s'affiche à l'écran le festival
Electric Park revient le premier et le 2
septembre ce sera et les équipes
viennent d'annoncer la programmation
définitive avec une tête d'affiche et
oui le plus grand festival de musique
électronique francilien et de retour un
rendez-vous incontournable installé sur
l'île des Impressionnistes à Chatou
depuis 2010 sera semblement gagne en
envergure chaque année avec 30000
spectateurs en 2022 alors on vient
d'apprendre que des artistes tel kagoria
FEDER ou modestep seront présents mais
surtout le public aura la chance de
découvrir la star internationale Robin
Schulz un artiste connu pour de nombreux
hits tels que sugar sun goes down ou ok
qui cumulent des centaines de millions
de vues sur Youtube on écoute quelques
extraits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on poursuit dans la musique Céline
avec une légende internationale du Jazz
qui a donné son nom à un lieu culturel à
Mantes-la-Jolie tout à fait le visage du
célèbre trompettiste Quincy Jones s'est
apparu sur la façade du Conservatoire à
rayonnement départemental à
Mantes-la-Jolie le célèbre compositeur
est producteur de 90 ans nés à Chicago
aux États-Unis obtenu 29 grimmy Awards
depuis 1964 l'artiste a notamment
collaboré avec Michael
Jackson je vais arriver à le dire Frank
Sinatra Michael ou encore Ray Charles
pourquoi le nom de ce musicien est bien
c'est grâce à un habitant de la commune
qui avait travaillé avec l'artiste un
nom proposé au directeur du
conservatoire qui a aussitôt été accepté
le principal intéressé Quincy Jones se
dit très touché par cette attention de
son ami français une soirée
d'inauguration aura lieu ce vendredi 16
juin en présence des habitants bien
merci beaucoup Céline charme pour toutes
ces informations et comme d'habitude si
vous aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
[Musique]
mardi dernier 5 délégation étrangères
ont été accueillis par la Maison de
l'Europe des Yvelines à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye ce meeting a pris
fin ce midi il s'inscrit dans le projet
JIRA pour les initiatives vertes en zone
rurale retour sur cette première journée
de réunion internationale avec Martin
Patry de radio sensation je suis à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye ou la Maison de
l'Europe des Yvelines et son centre
Europe Direct accueille 5 délégations
étrangères dans le cadre du projet Gira
un projet qui vise à mettre en valeur
des initiatives du pacte vert européen
dans des zones rurales et urbaines des
Yvelines la première visite commence dès
maintenant au centre de valorisation
thermique de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
[Musique]
alors le programme de la journée en fait
c'est de montrer deux sources d'énergie
renouvelables premièrement un forage
dont la couche albien à 600 mètres qui
produit deux ressources de l'eau potable
et de la chaleur et puis une deuxième
ressource renouvelable donc notre
chaudière biomasse en bas
qui lui brûle des plaquettes forestières
pour alimenter le réseau de chauffage
urbain l'objectif de la visite en fait
c'est pour le montrer à ce programme
européen montrer ce qu'on a réussi à
faire à Saint-Germain-en-Laye ça peut
donner des idées à d'autres villes c'est
toujours intéressant d'avoir leur
réactions les échanges je pense que
c'est très utile
c'était très intéressant pour moi de
visiter ces installations et de voir
comment elle fonctionne car je n'ai
jamais vu ça en Pologne ou même dans un
autre pays
donc effectivement je pense que vous
prenez beaucoup de bonnes initiatives
il est maintenant 15 heures direction la
ferme de Gally une entreprise familiale
dont le siège est situé près de
Saint-Cyr-l'École
qu'est-ce que vous avez montré aux
différentes délégations aujourd'hui pour
différentes délégations je t'aurais déjà
expliqué l'histoire de des fermes de
Galilée de cette entreprise familiale et
après nous sommes allés visites le
magasin de la ferme de Gally à
Saint-Cyr-l'École et on a vu les
différents univers
végétaux alimentaires les points de
restauration et puis de décoration et
après on est venu à la ferme pédagogique
de Saint-Cyr là où on se trouve
actuellement dans la visite de la ferme
de Gally parce que on est situé en
bordure de la ville et que c'est un
exemple de diversification du monde
agricole et
d'activités qui peuvent être apportées
par les acteurs du monde agricole et
lors de cette première journée les
différentes délégations se sont
également rendus ici au quartier du
Bel-Air où est mis en place depuis 2019
le projet axiome basé sur la solidarité
et le développement durable
et la préoccupation se fait de plus en
plus grande là où il y a quelques années
encore les pompiers des Yvelines étaient
peu susceptibles d'avoir à lutter contre
les feux de forêt le dérèglement un
climatique est la sécheresse change la
donne et les pompiers doivent s'adapter
fin mai et début juin ils ont suivi une
formation sur les feux de forêt pour en
parler avec nous le lieutenant-colonel
Stéphane Horn référent feu de forêt pour
les pompiers des Yvelines alors première
question qu'avez-vous effectué et a pris
lors de ces différentes formations alors
pour les différentes formations comme
toute spécialité chez les serpents
pompiers donc nous avons tronc commun
qui nous permet de faire l'incendie
urbain et le Soi personne et après des
spécialités diverses et variées qui vont
des conducteurs signaux techniques ceux
qui ont des chiens du risque chimique du
risque de sauvetage des blés il y a le
feu de forêt donc le feu de forêt c'est
une formation qu'on fait en plusieurs
niveaux et donc au sein des Yvelines
donc nous formons les équipiers et les
chefs d'agrès les chefs d'agrès se sont
ceux qui de l'engin donc on avait un
certain volume de formation qu'on
réalisait il y a encore quelques années
et ce volume a augmenté et donc ça
permet après aux équipages d'avoir la
bonne technique méthodologies
opérationnelle pour pouvoir éteindre un
feu de forêt qui est totalement
différent d'un et justement quel est
cette méthodologie alors pour répondre à
cette forêt la méthodologie la grande
différence c'est que lorsqu'on fait un
furbain a fait industriel c'est un feu
qui est on va dire statique il va pas
partir de de maison en maison en maison
pour brûler une ville entière alors
qu'un feu de forêt il a un point de
départ et en fait le vent le relief la
végétation font avancer ce feu et donc
nous nous avons comme méthodologie de
pouvoir resserrer ce qu'on appelle cette
tête de feu pour pouvoir parfaire son
extinction parce qu'il est très
difficile d'éteindre un feu de forêt le
commun des mortels lorsqu'il va un feu
de forêt vers un arbre qui brûle mais en
fait ce qui brûle essentiellement ce qui
est dangereux ce sont les essences qui
sont produites par cette végétation donc
il y a un risque qui vient particulier
et c'est un feu qu'on appelle dy et donc
on doit régulièrement s'adapter pour
pouvoir l'éteindre alors on va le voir
sur sur les images qui vont s'afficher
dans quelques instants vous avez
notamment utilisé voilà un mur d'eau
alors je ne sais pas comment est-ce que
vous l'appelez dans votre jargon de
pompier mais est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer à quoi ça sert et pourquoi
utiliser ce mur d'eau alors là dans la
vidéo qu'on a pu voir donc l'ensemble du
dispositif ce qu'on appelle un groupe
d'intervention feux de forêt qui
constituait de quatre véhicules feux de
forêt et d'un véhicule tout terrain ils
se sont mis en fait de façon à se
protéger c'est à dire qu'en fait à ce
moment-là ils sont pris par le feu le
feu va leur placer dessus on l'entend
souvent dans le Sud où il y a des
accidents des camions qui brûlent des
compétition blessés en fait on est pris
par le feu et en fait ce mur d'eau qu'on
utilise avec une lance que de Pan en
fait permet de protéger au moins
d'abaisser un peu la température du
front de flamme qui va arriver sur les
véhicules et ça permet dans la ferme de
protéger de ne pas mettre des
portes-lances ce qu'on appelle
directement à tenir l'annonce alors quel
autre citoyens vous avez à votre
disposition pour lutter contre ces feux
de forêt et notamment les
camions-citerne est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres outils alors dans les Yvelines
donc nous avons des véhicules qui sont
type peuforés donc ce qu'on appelle les
camions feux de forêt et ensuite on a
des camions qui sont des gros porteurs
doux puisque toute la difficulté c'est
lorsqu'on a en forêt c'est pas l'endroit
où on a le plus de poteau d'incendie ou
de bouche d'incendie donc l'eau il faut
la récupérer il y a des étangs
éventuellement sur lesquels qui ont été
ménagés sur lesquels on peut aspirer
l'eau mais en période de sécheresse ces
étangs et les niveaux ne font que
baisser et toute la difficulté c'est de
pérenniser l'arrivée en nous donc on a
des gros porteurs en nous qui sont là
donc pour alimenter les véhicules et
ensuite on a des moyens aériens tels que
des drones pour pouvoir faire des
reconnaissances et avoir une meilleure
vision de du feu alors la fumée
ça n'empêche pas les drones enfin ça
vous êtes quand même malgré la fumée oui
ça nous aide ça nous aide on le fait
dans un deuxième temps le drone pour
avoir une meilleure visibilité du feu et
lorsqu'il y a trop de fumées aussi on a
la possibilité d'utiliser les
hélicoptères de la sécurité civile donc
il se déplace à ce moment-là et donc un
officier qui est formé feu de forêt et
ce qu'on appelle Aero donc à la capacité
de lire un feu depuis un point haut
embarque avec le pilote d'hélicoptère et
le mécanicien ils font le tour du feu et
cette année est assez exceptionnel
puisque là tous les pompiers ont été
sensibilisés au feu de forêt alors tout
à fait donc là on a fait un gros travail
déjà pour sensibiliser tous les
officiers au feu de forêt il est
important parce que lorsqu'une
intervention prend de l'ampleur et vous
le comprenez pour un feu de forêt ça
prend vite de l'ampleur on a un système
pyramidal qui fait qu'au fur et à mesure
que l'intervention grandit qui est de
plus en plus de moyens des officiers de
différents grades viennent pour prendre
ce qu'on appelle le commandement des
opérations de secours vraiment pour
gérer toute l'intervention donc
forcément déjà si au niveau des
officiers il y a pas cette sensibilité
ou cette formation c'est problématique
donc il y a eu un gros travail qui a été
fait pour sensibiliser tous les
officiers de
lieutenant-colonel et colonel et alors
l'objectif
de le dérèglement climatique avec les
feux de forêt qui seront de plus en plus
fréquents dans les Yvelines ça sera de
plus en plus fréquent à tel point qu'en
2022 suite au grand feu l'état donc a
fait une dotation pour les départements
pour les 10 pour pouvoir se douter de
véhicules supplémentaires feux de forêt
alors ces véhicules supplémentaires ils
sont là pour renforcer ce qu'on appelle
les colonnes c'est à dire les renforts
c'est-à-dire que demain il y a un feu
important dans les Yvelines et je pense
qu'un jour ça arrivera c'est à dire
qu'on demandera des renforts d'autres
zones de France actuellement c'est nous
qui allons renfort on va en renfort dans
le sud-est dans le Sud-Ouest
chaque à chaque épisode estivale donc la
zone Île-de-France part en renfort en
France dans différentes zones où ils en
ont besoin et donc ces renforts sont des
renforts zones c'est-à-dire qu'on
constitue ce qu'on appelait une colonne
plusieurs véhicules donc avec les
départements du 91 du 95 77 78 alors
j'imagine que plus un incendie est
détecté tôt mieux et les maîtriser
est-ce que vous avez des outils pour
justement savoir quand un feu de forêt
se déclenche alors le meilleur des
outils avant tout c'est la prévention
c'est à dire que il faut éviter que ça
se déclenche donc c'est c'est du bon
usage de chacun qui visite les forêts
qu'on a dans nos massifs et là depuis
peu en fait on a une convention avec
l'ONF qui est vraiment le gestionnaire
des forêts qu'on peut avoir au niveau
des Yvelines qui les parcourent il les
connaissent par coeur et donc pareil eux
avec la dotation qu'ils ont eu de l'État
ils ont eu des véhicules de surveillance
voilà donc il y en a deux qui ont été
attribués dans le département des
Yvelines et eux sur les périodes de
risque sévère et très sévère
effectueront des zones de surveillance
sur des massifs et donc comme ça ils
pourront aussi avoir une première action
d'extinction d'un début de fenais 100
barbecue voilà quelque chose qui reste
très très limité et c'est eux qui nous
donneront l'alerte au plus vite en plus
des des randonneurs qui doivent le faire
alors est-ce qu'il y a des forêts que
vous surveillez plus que d'autres ou
alors que l'ONF surveille plus que
d'autres est-ce que vous savez s'il y a
des forêts qui sont plus à risque dans
le département non très sincèrement on
pourrait penser que le massif de
Rambouillet plus ça risque j'ai envie de
vous dire non parce que à Marly-le-Roi
aussi il y a des risques parce que il y
a pas que que la surface qui est brûlée
l'importance de la surface qui brûlait
nous ce qui nous intéresse le plus c'est
de d'assurer ce qu'on appelle les
protections de points sensibles donc
c'est une habitation c'est une ferme
c'est un outil de travail et donc on
peut aussi les avoir dans des zones
beaucoup plus urbanisées monsieur de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye voilà on est sur
des zones très urbanisées avec des axes
routiers donc non l'important c'est
il y a pas de massif plus important
qu'un autre
oui vous aviez une question allez-y
si oui qu'est-ce que vous faites pour le
couvrir alors le manque d'eau est un
risque mais quoi qu'il arrive donc nous
on est sur les réseaux d'hydran on est
sur des réseaux d'hydran qui nous
permettent quand même de d'avoir une
certaine voilà une certaine continuité
de l'eau il est certain que utiliser
comme je disais les étangs les surfaces
naturelles c'est compliqué par exemple
si on peut lui massif de Rambouillet un
point d'eau où on peut facilement
respirer c'est les stands Hollande tout
le monde connaît voilà forcément si un
moment le niveau ne fait que baisser
baisser baisser baisser ça sera
problématique donc non la meilleure des
réponses qu'on a actuellement c'est se
doter de véhicules en préventif avec des
grandes capacités en eau dans ces
véhicules qui ont à peu près 10 ml d'eau
et de pouvoir les remplir et les engager
rapidement
et bien merci beaucoup lie
utenant d'avoir répondu à nos questions
un mot d'économie à présent avec la
chronique de Véronique Jérôme Polito
économiste et maître de conférence à
l'Université de Paris Saclay pour ce
numéro elle s'intéresse à la transition
écologique qui la finance et comment la
financer voici quelques pistes de
réponse
[Musique]
notre maison brûle toujours qui en
douterait désormais et pourtant toute
décision face à cette urgence absolue et
souvent ressenti comme une contribution
quasi sacrificielle requise des
générations présentes finançant des
mesures à destination des générations
futures la contrainte écologique se
double d'une contrainte économique et
rien n'est négociable s'ajoute la
contrainte de la gouvernance de bien
public mondiaux mais si le ciel est à
tout le monde ce qui est à tout le monde
est à personne dès lors qu'il ne s'agit
plus de profiter mais de financer
l'humanité partage la propriété commune
d'une planète en souffrance que certains
acceptent d'entretenir au bénéfices du
plus grand nombre mais nul marcher pour
exclure ses opportunistes freeriders
reste après coup visant un
pollueur-payeur une fiscalité punitive
ou encore un marché des droits à polluer
mais vouloir freiner l'anthropocène en
tentant de généraliser
famille circulaire report modal ou
sobriété énergétique ou numérique c'est
risqué de réduire les acquis de
l'innovation quand on conférence
internationale elle peine à convaincre
les pays au-delà de l'engagement de
passer à l'action les réticences
justifiées par des contraintes de
financement à l'échelle du pays la
nature publique du bien engage la
responsabilité de l'État il peut
actionner le levier de la fiscalité plus
d'impôts aujourd'hui ou le levier de
l'endettement plus d'impôts demain en
découle alors les questions du
consentement et de l'assujettissement à
l'impôt ainsi que la soutenabilité de la
dette publique boulait auquel on
enchaîne les générations futures l'État
central a besoin du Relais des
territoires le pacte vert européen doit
s'appuyer sur des initiatives en
provenance et à destination des
territoires existe déjà un fond vert de
thé de 2 milliards d'euros pour
l'investissement un tiers financement
pour la rénovation énergétique ou encore
une agence nationale de la la décision
des territoires fournissant l'ingénierie
et bientôt un porte-à-porte de la part
de BPI France à destination de 20000 PME
et et afin de faciliter la décarbonation
de l'industrie sans oublier en région
Île-de-France une mise sous contrôle de
l'artificialisation mais aussi un
renforcement du maillage territorial
opéré par les transports en commun
s'ajoute la nécessité d'aller vers un
état une bureaucratie de taille
maîtrisée bureaucratie omniprésente et
état hyperactif génère des effets
contre-productifs pour les territoires
pour preuve le projet de consigne des
bouteilles en plastique transparent
s'inscrivant dans l'objectif européen
d'un taux de collecte de 90% d'ici 2029
en concurrençant les bacs jaunes
menacent la rentabilité des centres de
recyclage des territoires la lutte
contre les soupes de plastique dans les
océans l'équivalent d'un camion toutes
les minutes méritent mieux que ça la
solution peut être le décentrisme d'une
nouvelle gouvernance avec état central
et local BPI France et bande des
territoires les entreprises ETI PME mais
aussi des grands groupes industriels ou
non tous acteurs de ce polycentrisme
responsable et plus autonome facilitant
une innovation bénéfique au plus grand
nombre cherchant à rendre compatible une
dette verte s'ajoutant au dette
existantes et tranchant la question de
nouveaux impôts verts inévitable pour le
rapport pisaniferi mais contrariant
l'annonce du politique promettant plus
de nouvelles taxes ainsi forcé de
constater que nulissu n'est envisageable
sans le retour d'une croissance durable
et suffisante enfin gardons en mémoire
ces derniers encouragements de la Nobel
d'économie et du Nord au schtroumph
l'objectif central des politiques
publiques devrait être plutôt de
faciliter le développement
d'institutions qui font ressortir ce
qu'il y a de meilleur chez les humains
[Musique]
allez on ouvre une petite page culture à
présent le théâtre Coluche de plaisir va
révéler sa prochaine saison culturelle
pour l'année 2023 2024 demain soir et
pour nous parler de la programmation la
directrice de la salle Florence Camoin
pour cette nouvelle saison culturelle
Florence cama vous avez sélectionné de
la danse des concerts des comédies ou
des pièces un petit peu plus dures parmi
elles ne m'a rien dit qui porte sur la
question des violences faites aux femmes
et du féminicide oui effectivement on
commence très très fort mais c'est un
sujet essentiel dans la brochure il est
dit que tous les deux jours et demi une
femme meurt sous les coups de son
compagnon et Hakim a rencontré une femme
totalement extraordinaire je suis la
chance de pas lui parler mais de l'avoir
et sur scène et de voir cette femme
lumineuse Agathe ager Sailly qui
a été malheureusement confronté à
l'assassinat de sa petite sœur qui était
handicapée et
les garçons conjoint alors que la veille
elle était allée porter plainte à la
police et elle a mis 10 ans pour obtenir
la condamnation de l'État pour
non-assistance à personne en danger donc
c'est un sujet très fort je veux pas
tout raconter l'intrigue c'est une
histoire vraie c'est Hakim Jaziri qui a
adapté la pièce d'après le témoignage
d'agir et tout cela va être accompagné
aussi de beaucoup de rencontres avec le
public parce que c'est un fléau c'est un
tic tac c'est un compte à rebours de
massacre de femmes qui continuent qui
continue en France et qui est contre
lequel il faut lutter puisqu'il y a eu
cette loi en 2021 qui est totalement
passée sous silence puisqu'il y avait le
covid quand vous dites rencontre avec le
public ça veut dire que la pièce elle
est interactive que oui il y aura un
échange avec la salle à l'issue il y
aura aussi des rencontres dans les
diverses associations de la ville notre
d'autant plus qu'un plaisir il y a une
maison qui s'appelle la maison Calypso
qui est consacrée aux femmes qui sont
victimes de violence
donc c'était d'autant plus important de
soutenir cette création puisque c'est
une création en ce moment ils sont en
train de travailler de répéter donc je
ne l'ai pas vu j'ai vu des lectures j'ai
assisté à des démonstrations de
d'extrait de la pièce mais je n'ai pas
vu le spectacle mais comme je connais un
autre spectacle dont on va peut-être
parler tout à l'heure je sais qu'il y a
un talent
justement donc il y a une autre pièce
qui fait réfléchir du même metteur en
scène c'est désaxé je vous propose de
regarder un extrait et on en parle juste
après
mon fils
[Musique]
le McDonald's le nutella la Tour Eiffel
la chose
ça fait deux mois qu'on est en France ah
Aulnay-sous-Bois dans la cité des 3000
on va à l'école pour la première fois
mais dans ma tête tout ça ça va pas
durer j'ai déjà mon école
et ça veut dire qu'on rentre pas chez
nous tout de suite maman
non mon fils va tout de suite
laissez maintenant comment ça marche le
premier qui me cherche
[Musique]
alors dans cette pièce on suit un
prisonnier qui écrit à ses parents
depuis la prison de Fleury-Mérogis il
retrace son parcours jusqu'à ce qu'il
devienne presque un djihadiste c'est une
pièce qui a l'air très saisissante elle
est très forte je l'ai découverte au
Festival d'Avignon et ça a été
je sais pas c'est un coup de poing qu'on
se prend dans la figure parce que en
fait on se pose pas forcément on a vu le
Bataclan on a vu plein de choses on a
été on a eu des amis qui ont été
victimes mais on sait pas en fait tout
ce qui se cache derrière et comment se
font les recrutements et comment
certains jeunes sont happés et d'autres
arrivent à s'en sortir et donc c'est
voilà c'est encore une histoire qui
nécessite qu'on en parle qu'on en parle
aux jeunes qui a un témoignage et que
qu'on apprenne aux jeunes surtout aux
jeunes je pense beaucoup à eux à
réfléchir par eux-mêmes et pas se
laisser embrigader par les adultes qui
n'ont pas forcément toujours les bonnes
réponses et c'est une pièce quasi
autobiographique parce que c'est arrivé
à Kim Jaziri donc il sait de quoi il
parle et il sait comment il s'en est
sortis donc c'est passionnant fascinant
bon après avoir parlé de deux pièces un
peu sérieuses un peu dur je vous propose
de parler de comédie parce que dans
votre programmation vous avez laissé une
grande place à l'humour tout de même
notamment avec cette pièce une idée
géniale qui a reçu deux Molières
exactement et je l'ai programmé avant de
le savoir
et alors de quoi on parle dans cette
pièce c'est une histoire de Sosie c'est
la deuxième pièce de Sébastien Castro il
a déjà eu je crois le Molière de la
meilleure comédie pour la précédente et
en fait
il a des sosie et donc il joue tous les
sosies évidemment et et les autres
rencontrent les différences sosies et se
perdent dans ces sosies parce qu'ils
savent jamais lequel est le bon et
lui-même ne sait pas qui il est
finalement mais c'est impossible à
raconter mais c'est 30 oui c'est un rire
toutes les 30 secondes quoi c'est
complètement délirant il y a Paul si
qu'il accompagne c'est les deux grandes
l'humour actuellement en France donc
voilà c'est pour passer le moment de un
moment de pure délire c'est juste pour
ça fait du bien quoi de l'humour aussi
avec plusieurs one man show ou one woman
show notamment avec Thomas N'Gijol âge
Christelle Cholet ou encore Laura Laune
vous avez mis le paquet là cette année
parce qu'ils sont tous tellement
différents et c'est peut-être même à
chaque fois pas forcément la même cils
cible et bon Tom and jijol je n'ai rien
vu si vous allez sur Internet vous
voulez voir la bande-annonce il y a rien
si vous voulez voir le spectacle bah
faut y aller la bande-annonce est basée
sur allez voir il veut garder ça c'est
Laura Laune c'est totalement trash c'est
interdit au moins de 16 ans donc
personne n'envoie ces jeunes de moins de
16 ans voir ce spectacle où il en prend
la responsabilité azat c'est vraiment
des des petites saynètes de vie qui sont
absolument hilarantes et Christelle
Chollet il y a aussi la chanson dans sa
dimension artistique il y a aussi la
femme de 50 ans c'est vraiment très
différent en fait c'est c'est de
l'humour oui mais on peut faire de
l'humour de tellement de façon et alors
en fait des Jeux olympiques de Paris
2024 vous avez aussi programmé une pièce
celle d'un sportif de saut à ce qui
c'est une histoire vraie elle se nomme
vol et dit vol j'aime bien les histoires
vraies surtout quand elles sont
totalement dingues c'est l'histoire d'un
jeune Anglais qui voulait participer aux
Jeux olympiques mais c'est pas facile
parce qu'il y a plein de fédérations
avec plein de possibilités de d'y
participer seulement quand on est malin
et qu'on veut vraiment y participer on
va créer sa propre fédération et
imaginez créer la Fédération anglaise de
saut à ski ça n'existait pas donc il
était le seul et il a réussi à battre à
faire le saut le plus le minimum pour
pouvoir participer aux Jeux Olympiques
ce qui fait que quand il y a il a
réellement participé aux Jeux Olympiques
à la fois on le voit sur une petite télé
remercie les acteurs d'avoir raconté son
histoire et c'était tellement dingue que
c'est lui qui a été le plus applaudit en
fait mais franchement la pièce c'est
pareil c'est une comédie mais c'est une
comédie qui donne la banane justement je
vous propose de regarder un extrait on
continue d'en parler juste après je
m'appelle Michael Edwards mais tout le
monde m'appelle Eddy
le rêve que j'ai fait cette nuit j'ai dû
le faire environ
746 fois moi participant aux Jeux
olympiques d'hiver
les Jeux Olympiques c'est une blague
c'est une blague Michael on s'improvise
pas sportive de haut niveau c'est mon
rêve papa bah justement
aucun participant britannique n'a été
référencé dans la catégorie soski aux
Jeux olympiques d'hiver aucun
ce qui veut dire que j'ai réussi en saut
en 71 mètres de long sous les couleurs
de la Grande-Bretagne tu verras la
torche olympique de près
alors elle a l'air formidable cette
histoire est-ce que ça vous donne envie
d'y aller en plateau
alors vous proposez également des
soirées spéciales cette année Florence
Camon une soirée spéciale reggae et une
soirée spéciale latina je vous propose
qu'on en parle juste après mais avant
regarder un extrait pour qu'on puisse se
mettre dans l'ambiance
[Musique]
alors on a vu deux groupes se
succédaient le premier groupe au compe
secondo et combien boroka il promettent
d'enflammer la scène de la clé des
champs alors c'est pas seulement en fait
on a travaillé ensemble avec Frédéric
poletto qui est directeur de la clé des
champs qui est notre scène de musique
actuelle et qui entraîne en plein essor
et on a voulu ouvrir tout le bâtiment ça
veut dire que ça commencera
à la clé des champs avec le DJ
ortegadogo qui sera là demain soir donc
si vous voulez faire une profitez d'une
soirée endiablée ça commence demain à
20h30 au Théâtre Coluche parce que voilà
et puis après on fera la fête après vous
avoir présenté tous les spectacles et
donc le fameux groupo Compay Segundo
dont je suis totalement fan dont j'ai
tous les disques et la découverte de ce
groupe latino hyper enviable et de
combien boruca et après le DJ on va
danser à la clé des champs ça va être
mais complètement fou et on le fera une
deuxième fois en mars avec la soirée
regga reggae avec Tiken Jah Fakoly et
d'autres petites surprises il y aura
encore trois autres groupes et ça sera
le la même ambiance on ouvre tout le
bâtiment le Conservatoire va faire des
initiations vont être voilà ce sera la
folie et bien merci beaucoup Florence
cammin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
alors si vous êtes intéressé le théâtre
Coluche de plaisir fait sa soirée de
présentation demain soir à 20h30 vous
pourrez réserver vos places à partir du
mardi 20 juin 14h et sinon vous pouvez
toujours retrouver toute la
programmation sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran allez on
ouvre une page loisirs maintenant
[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisir avec la
semaine du beach volley il s'agit d'une
première édition c'est un événement à
porter national qui aura lieu également
dans les Yvelines dans l'enceinte du
stade Georges Lefèvre à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye du 16 au 18 juin
pour en parler avec nous ivandre Vallot
le vice-président du club du Vésinet
stade saint-germain-nois volley-ball
alors quel est le programme de ces trois
jours un programme très très riche tout
d'abord nous allons commencer par demain
matin 9h un tournoi de qualification qui
va réunir les 12 pairs garçons et filles
nationales et donc à l'issue de ces
qualifications les quatre meilleures
équipes basculeront dans un tournoi
principal qui commencera le samedi matin
mais nous terminerons la journée du
vendredi par tirer les finales de notre
challenge un scolaire un bitcheur que
nous avons lancé cette année où on aura
en finale des moins de 18 ans du des
lycées Alain et des lycées donc Jeanne
d'Albret de Saint-Germain et il y aura
trois villages un village sportif un
village partenaire et un village public
tout à fait donc venez nombreux donc on
aura beaucoup d'animations pour les
jeunes et moins jeunes et donc qui
seront à côté des animations enfin des
sports à la fois Beach volley-ball mais
aussi on aura un volet handicap qui se
déroulera le samedi soir et le dimanche
on aura l'occasion d'avoir les finales
quart de finale demi-finale finale avec
la remise des récompenses dans
l'après-midi vers 16h30 17h et donc on
aura le tour de ça un certain nombre
d'animations dans le dans les tribunes
aussi vous aurez des des tests de sauts
de temps pure de joueurs des vélos
smoothies des jeux de ballons
c'est quoi en en faisant son
smoothie
après avoir fait un petit effort donc
renouvelable tout à fait et alors niveau
sportif ce week-end on aurait également
les 20 meilleurs équipes de France
donc on a trois niveaux au niveau beach
volley français on a le 3 le 2 et le 1
le 1 étant le plus haut niveau et donc
au plus haut niveau on a le 1500 2000 ou
2500 de 2500 correspond moi je dirais au
nombre de points que vont acquérir c'est
comme au tennis donc les vainqueurs et
ensuite il y a ce qu'on appelle un money
price aussi qui est attribué au
vainqueur donc en France on a un seul
tournoi S1 de 1500 il est à
Saint-Germain donc et ça sera ce weekend
démonstration
moi je vous invite à venir parce que
d'abord le Beach volley-ball il est
connu par tout le monde puisque
aujourd'hui on a à peu près recensé 1
million 800 000 Français qui font du
Beach volley-ball principalement l'été
sur les plages alors nous en région
parisienne au département 78 on n'a pas
beaucoup de plages donc on a la chance
d'avoir ce qu'on appelle des spots de
Beach où les gens essaient de
s'entraîner alors cette année c'est un
petit peu difficile mais à partir du
mois de l'été prochain de du mois de
juillet de août on va avoir une halle de
Beach à Croissy-sur-Seine donc on va
gérer couvrir l'ensemble de boucles de
saigne on va pouvoir faire du Beach
volley-ball toute l'année donc c'est une
bonne nouvelle donc c'est un million
800000 aujourd'hui bitscher qui vont
faire de la du du jeu de sable avec les
parents avec les enfants etc sur les
plages françaises et bien vont se
retrouver je dirais sur des spots de
Beach comme ça dans dans les terres et
dans et dans les régions françaises qui
ne sont pas en bord de mer et donc nous
on a la chance d'avoir d'avoir un spot
magnifique au stade Georges le fait qui
est en plus le site qui a été choisi par
la Grande-Bretagne que par la délégation
britannique pour les JO donc voilà donc
il a été totalement je dirais réaménagé
pour accueillir la Grande-Bretagne et
donc nous on a installé c'est pour ça
j'ai juste avant je suis arrivé un petit
peu juste pour l'émission on a installé
un magnifique spot avec une Arena 400
places de tribune pour accueillir
l'ensemble des l'ensemble des visiteurs
donc 20 meilleures paires françaises
garçons et filles le beach volley c'est
du 2 2 donc c'est assez spectaculaire et
puis je dis bon là c'est le toucher le
sable est trop bord avec de la musique
national d'esprit fun festif c'est une
très bonne transition pour avoir les
vacances des vacances d'été parce que il
y a des amateurs de beach-volley autour
de ce plateau Céline Charles Florence
de vacances pour moi voilà c'est le rêve
quoi c'est la plage le sable et puis les
amis surtout venez voir l'ambiance dans
les tribunes sur le sable la musique en
permanence voilà écran géant etc voilà
il y aura une magnifique fête pendant
trois journées et je vous invite à venir
nombreux à cet événement alors il s'agit
d'une première édition
dans la Genèse on s'était on voulait
faire on a lancé je dirais ce
développement du beat volley-ball au
sein du club il y a un peu plus de 2 ans
la responsabilité au sein du club du
Vésinet qui est de Saint-Germain qui
représente aujourd'hui depuis 400
adhérents mais principalement
principalement des adhérents en salle et
donc l'idée c'est d'amener plus de
jeunes sur le sur le sable et donc on a
décidé d'aller d'avoir comment mission
300 bitscher d'ici deux trois ans donc
308 heures donc avec une activité toute
l'année ça va être possible pardon ça va
être possible avec une Val de et
donc on s'est dit pour pouvoir gérer
atteindre cette ambition il faut une
feuille de route et dans cette feuille
de route il faut un programme
événementiel et donc on a organisé
depuis ces deux dernières années
beaucoup beaucoup de tournois mais des
petits tournois S3 S2 et cette année on
passe une marche supplémentaire en
disant voilà on veut avoir un grand
tournoi mais on s'est dit un tournoi de
beach simplement c'est pas suffisant
donc on a voulu vraiment avoir un
événement innovant et on s'est dit on va
organiser un triptyque
du scolaire partie du question du
handicap inclusion et du haut niveau et
je vais réunir tous ces gens là et
demain soir par exemple dans le volet
handicap on fera j'irai non c'est sur le
sable on aura dévalides du haut niveau
et puis des gens handicapés qui feront
finalement du volet assis sur le sable
en qui combattront au cours d'un petit
match comme ça de démonstration et alors
au niveau juste des informations
pratiques qu'est-ce qu'il faut savoir
est-ce qu'il faut réserver est-ce que
c'est gratuit c'est tout à fait gratuit
vous avez donc on a la chance de stage
je le fais qui desservie par le tram 13
donc vous venez à vélo si vous êtes en
proximité vous avez des grands parkings
à côté à proximité aussi vous avez le
RER A jusqu'à Saint-Germain vous avez le
tram qui vient de Saint-Germain vous
avez le tram qui vient de plaisir aussi
donc voilà c'est assez bien des services
j'irai l'espace est extraordinaire
puisqu'on a la volé la forêt de
Saint-Germain tout autour le grand air
il y aura la Restauration il y aura tout
ce qu'il faut pour passer une
trois journées exceptionnelles
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je le
rappelle la semaine du beach-volée c'est
à partir de demain 9h jusqu'à dimanche
18h et ce sera au stade Georges Lefebvre
de Saint-Germain-en-Laye chaque année 50
000 brocantes et vide-greniers sont
organisés un peu partout en France et
les Yvelines ne dérochent pas à la règle
pris un battable négociation vider les
garages ou les remplir les raisons du
succès sont multiples en mai dernier la
ville de Villepreux organisée la sienne
le reportage de Mélanie poquet la télé à
50 euros
me fait à 10 euros et l'autre c'est un
support pour fixer la télé au mur
ok on fait un tour et après on va
afficher merci beaucoup monsieur
Géraldine est une habituée des brocantes
après de nombreux rendez-vous en
Eure-et-Loir c'est la première fois que
cette lessienne vont dans les Yvelines à
Villepreux à 13h à l'avait déjà écoulé
une bonne partie de son stock son secret
le sourire la politesse de dire bonjour
et voilà si un coup de coeur des fois
négocient je dis oui après ça c'est trop
bas je dis non donc ça dépend mais voilà
j'avoue je suis contente parce que ce
matin c'était bien plein et là
actuellement non je suis contente
vêtements vaisselle jouer livre il faut
farfouiller pour faire de belles
découvertes des instants que beaucoup
apprécient cette période d'inflation et
post covid les petits prix attirent la
variété la qualité et les petits prix
bien sûr je marchande bon ça dépend
honnêtement un Euro 2 euros on va pas
marchander mais à partir de 5 6 voilà on
essaie de grappiller un petit euro
les gens trouvent des articles pas chers
et puis je trouve que c'est convivial et
jouer en fait il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de de petites choses à dénicher qu'on
trouvera pas effectivement en magasin et
puis avec la passion
ce qui fait que bah là il y a vraiment
la possibilité de trouver quelque chose
d'assez abordable qu'on fait des petits
prix donc c'est plus pour des encombrer
et des mes enfants aussi dans la dans la
démarche il y a possibilité de négocier
le but c'est de repartir avec moins que
ce dont on est venu voilà les brocantes
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce n'est pas
terminé prochain rendez-vous mord pas et
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les bonnes
affaires vous attendent
elle est comme chaque jeudi à l'approche
du week-end c'est l'heure de vous
partager nos idées de sortie Céline
c'est vous qui nous partagez vos bons
plans ce soir et on commence avec une
activité un peu insolite oui Mathilde
est-ce que vous saviez que l'on pouvait
jouer de la musique avec des boîtes de
conserve ou encore fabriquer des flux de
traversière avec des tuyaux en PVC non
du tout et bien si cela vous intrigue ni
collabra youtubeur et créateur de la
chaîne musique de nulle part vous en dit
un peu plus lors d'un atelier
fabrication d'instruments ça se passe ce
samedi 17 juin de 14h30 à 16h30 à la
médiathèque de cette Mara et l'encours
alors Nicolas est spécialiste de la
fabrication d'instruments avec des
matériaux du quotidien ou de récup qui
partagera avec vous quelques-unes de ces
astuces la réservation est conseillée
pour cet atelier mais attention les
enfants doivent avoir plus de 10 ans
pour pouvoir participer et si l'on est
un peu plus gourmand on peut se rendre à
La Verrière la ville organise les Happy
Days il y a l'occasion des Journées
Nationales Happy Days les 15 16 et 17
juin plusieurs événements dans toute la
France par les partenaires abeilles
sentinelles de l'environnement et
certains apiculteurs c'est dans ce cadre
que la verrière vous invite à participer
à de nombreuses animations et
découvertes autour de l'abeille samedi
17 juin de 9h à 17h au centre
socio-culturel Jacques Michel au
programme rencontre avec des apiculteurs
exposition extraction et dégustation de
miel ou encore atelier pédagogique et
ludique pour les enfants alors cette
année le thème c'est l'abeille et le
boulevers le bouleversement climatique
ces journées ont aussi pour but de
sensibiliser et d'informer au maximum la
population sur la prote la protection de
cette espèce et alors après ces deux
activités on peut prolonger sa journée
avec de la musique alors exactement
Mathilde le festival chapiteau sonore
revient ce samedi 17 dans le parc du
château éphémère de
Carrières-sous-Poissy à partir de 15
heures vous pouvez venir participer à un
atelier familial autour de la
fabrication d'instruments c'est
décidément l'activité du weekend et le
soir surtout vous allez pouvoir célébrer
le début de l'été avec une belle
programmation musicale alors sous le
chapiteau et en terrasse de la soul RnB
de l'électro pop électro ou encore de la
pop alternative bar restante de
restauration vous accompagneront sur
place tout le long de la soirée l'entrée
est libre pour tout le monde mais les
réservations restent néanmoins
conseillées et si en revanche vous êtes
plutôt jazz électro sachez que le Jazz
Festival la maison Lafitte est également
de retour du 16 au 25 juin 20 concerts
et pas moins de 104 artistes se
produiront pour vous à travers
différentes scènes swing boogie-woogie
jazz manouche et même funk sont à
l'affiche alors cette année le samedi 17
justement vous aurez par exemple la
possibilité de voir en concert l'artiste
jazz et néo-soul kids et de et la
saxophoniste française Sophie à lourd
programmation complète à retrouver sur
leur site internet et alors si on
préfère la danse Céline vous avez aussi
une activité à nous proposer et oui pas
de jaloux il y en a pour tout le monde
dans les Yvelines l'école de danse de
Saint-Cyr-l'École organise son gala de
danse dimanche 18 juin à 14h30 ou à
17h30 au théâtre au Théâtre Gérard
Philipe de la ville intitulé cinq sens
les élèves vous présenteront de la danse
classique et contemporaine l'occasion
peut-être aussi de faire connaître cette
discipline à vos enfants en vue de la
rentrée en septembre et enfin Céline
vous terminez par une activité un peu
plus calme oui je m'adresse cette
fois-ci au plus zen d'entre vous ceux
qui ont justement besoin de calme avant
d'enchaîner sur les activités que je
vous ai présentées je vous propose un
atelier yoga en plein cœur de l'Espace
Rambouillet c'est samedi 17 de 10h à
midi alors vous allez pouvoir commencer
par une marche méditative et poursuivre
par une séance de yoga dans la forêt
sauvage le reste de la journée vous
pourrez visiter le parc à votre guise
les débutants sont acceptés rendez-vous
sur le site de l'Espace Rambouillet pour
réserver et bien merci beaucoup Céline
Charles pour toutes ces idées de sortie
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'oeil à la
météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin il fera toujours aussi beau
dans les Yvelines au niveau des
températures il fera 21 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles et 20
degrés à Houdan et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le ciel sera toujours assez
dégagé prévoyez seulement quelques
nuages côté température il fera 28
degrés à Versailles 29 degrés à Houdan
et Rambouillet et 30 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et c'est devenu un
rendez-vous maintenant pour les
prévisions météo de ce week-end à la
présentation Thomas Fletcher je crois
qu'il s'est essayé au surf ou au
wakeboard plus précisément regarder
alors quoi de beau salut à tous alors
quoi de beau ce week-end dans les
Yvelines sachez que dimanche c'est la
fête des pères donc j'ai ramené ma paire
super super
on perd un peu de froid il fait hyper
beau et pour la fête des pères ça tombe
un jour un père et dimanche petite
journée pépère mais c'est aussi la
journée du
bonne fête à tous vos pères
et rien ne se perd
c'est le moment
[Musique]
on va attendre les vagues
en aucun
[Musique]
c'est la bonne c'est la bonne
encore encore
accélère un peu avec lui
[Musique]
moi
j'ai plus de bras mais c'est cool
[Musique]
alors quoi de beau
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir été avec nous je vous souhaite
une belle soirée sur TV 78 et un
excellent weekend prenez soin de vous
[Musique]